WHEN WE THINK ABOUT NATIONAL
SECURITY THREATS, THE FIRST
THING TO COME TO MIND PROBABLY
IS NOT A PHONE APP.
BUT THE HEAD OF THE CIA IS
WORRIED ABOUT JUST THAT WITH
THE APP TIKTOK.
>> I MEAN, I THINK IT IS A
GENUINE CONCERN FOR THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT.
IN THE SENSE THAT BECAUSE THE
PARENT COMPANY OF TIKTOK IS A
CHINESE COMPANY, THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT IS ABLE TO, YOU KNOW,
INSIST UPON EXTRACTING THE
PRIVATE DATA OF A LOT OF TIKTOK
USERS IN THIS COUNTRY AND ALSO
TO CHASE THE --
TO SUE THE INTERESTS OF THE
CHINESE LEADERSHIP.
I THINK THOSE ARE REAL
CHALLENGES.
>> HE CALLS IT, QUOTE,
TROUBLING.
AND ONCE FAMILIES TO BE, QUOTE,
REALLY CAREFUL WHEN IT COMES TO
KIDS USING TIKTOK.
NEARLY 20 STATES NOW BANNED
TIKTOK ON THEIR GOVERNMENT
DEVICES OR NETWORK.
VIRGINIA, MONTANA, IDAHO AND
WYOMING ARE AMONG THE LATEST.
RIGHT HERE IN WASHINGTON, THE
SENATE THIS WEEK PAST THE SAME
KIND OF BAN FOR FEDERAL
DEVICES.
BUT IT IS NOT CLEAR IF THE
HOUSE WILL DO ANYTHING.
THE U.S. MILITARY, THE STATE
DEPARTMENT, AND HOMELAND
SECURITY ARE ALL LIMITING
TIKTOK.
SO, WHAT ABOUT THE REST OF US?
TECH REPORTER STEPHANIE
HUMPHREY JOINS US NOW.
ALL RIGHT.
STEPHANIE, WHY ARE THESE
OFFICIALS AND TAX ACUITY EXPERT
SAYING WE NEED TO GET TIKTOK
OFF OUR PHONES AND TABLETS?
>> I THINK THE MAIN REASON --
THANK YOU FOR HAVING, ME BY THE
WAY.
I THINK THE MAIN REASON IS
BECAUSE TIKTOK'S PARENT COMPANY
IS A CHINESE COMPANY.
THEY ARE BASED IN SINGAPORE,
CURRENTLY.
AND THEY DO HAVE TO COMPLY WITH
THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT'S
REQUEST FOR PERSONAL DATA IF
THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT WAS TO
MAKE THAT REQUEST.
THEY WOULD BE COMPELLED TO --
THE IDEA THAT FEDERAL EMPLOYEES
ARE GOVERNMENT EMPLOYEES IN
GENERAL COULD HAVE TIKTOK ON
THEIR WORK PHONES AND HAVE
INFORMATION ON THOSE PHONES BE
COMPROMISED IS A VALID CONCERN
I THINK FOR PEOPLE IN THIS
COUNTRY.
>> IT IS ONE THING IF IT IS A
GOVERNMENT EMPLOYEE, IF IT'S ON
THE WORK PHONE.
BUT WHAT ABOUT A TEENAGER WHO
IS PUTTING UP FUNNY VIDEOS OF
DANCING OR, YOU KNOW, WHATEVER
THE CASE MAY BE?
WHY SHOULD THEY WORRY ABOUT
WHAT THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT
COULD SEE ON THEIR PHONES?
>> I THINK THE WORRY IS
PROBABLY A LITTLE LESS FOR SORT
OF THE AVERAGE CONSUMER THAT
MIGHT BE USING TIKTOK
CURRENTLY.
I THINK THE MAIN CONCERN IN
THAT INSTANCE IS THE WAY THAT
THE ALGORITHM WORKS AND THE
FACT THAT THE GOVERNMENT COULD
HAVE SOME SORT OF CONTROL OVER
WHAT PEOPLE ACTUALLY SEE ON THE
APP.
THE IDEA THAT SOME CONTACT
MIGHT BE CENSORED, BUT ALSO
THAT MISINFORMATION MIGHT GET
PROMOTED, ESPECIALLY TO YOUNGER
PEOPLE, WHO DON'T HAVE A GOOD
SENSE OF DIGITAL LITERACY OR
WHO MAY NOT HAVE A BETTER SENSE
OF DIGITAL LITERACY, COULD BE
SUSCEPTIBLE TO MANIPULATION
WITH THE CONTENT THAT THEY SEE.
>> SO, HERE IS HOW TIKTOK
RESPONSE.
QUOTE, WE ARE DISAPPOINTED THAT
SO MANY STATES ARE JUMPING ON
THE BANDWAGON TO ENACT POLICIES
THAT BASED ON UNFOUNDED,
POLITICALLY-CHARGED FALSEHOODS
ABOUT TIKTOK.
IT IS UNFORTUNATE THAT THE MANY
STATE AGENCIES, OFFICES, AND
UNIVERSITIES --
WILL NO LONGER BE ABLE TO USE
IT TO BUILD COMMUNITIES AND
CONNECT WITH CONSTITUENTS.
DO YOU SEE TIKTOK BEING ABLE TO
OVERCOME DOUBTS ABOUT SAFETY?
>> YEAH.
BECAUSE I THINK EVERY OTHER
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORM ASKED ON
THE SAME THING.
I THINK WITH THE AMOUNT OF
PEOPLE ON THE PLATFORM RIGHT
NOW, WE ARE CLOSE TO ABOUT A
BILLION USERS WORLDWIDE ON
TIKTOK.
AND WITH THE AMOUNT OF CREATORS
THAT ARE MAKING A LIVING ON
THIS PLATFORM, AND CONNECTING
AND BEING EDUCATED ON THIS
PLATFORM, I THINK WILL BE VERY,
VERY DIFFICULT TO CONVINCE
PEOPLE THAT THE SECURITY RISK